good evening and welcome to macabre
books this evening were very pleased to
be able to welcome David by Dennis the
author of e equals mc-squared a
biography of the world's most famous
equation we've all been transfixed in
the last couple of days by great
historical events so I thank you all for
coming out and taking some time to think
about probably one of the most momentous
scientific events if you will of our
time and David's book really takes a
very interesting look at that and in
terms of looking at the equation and
doing a so-called biography David is a
native of Chicago he was educated at the
University of Chicago but has been
living in the UK for a number of years
he teaches at Oxford and lives in London
and he's also the author of six previous
books including the best-selling the
secret house so please help me welcome
David go Dennis thank you some people
from the war camp have been very very
fussy and complained that this equation
was put on the ballots in Florida and I
think that's fair enough
it wasn't too hard and it was not done
by Jeb Bush I loved writing this book
that's how I ended the acknowledgments
and it really really is true I've
written a number of books all of which I
told the publishers came out well and
easily but only one or two did and this
was one of them there was something
about this book that I felt I was coming
home with it and I was trying to think
why why was that what seems so familiar
a number of people have come up to me
and said that they they they also they
felt ready for and I realized that that
was something that Einstein himself once
said somebody asked him how did it feel
to be to be Einstein to to disk I
described and find these great things he
said he felt like a little boy going
into a big big library maybe like this
bookstore but the difference is we can
read all the books here and he said he
couldn't read the books they were in a
language he couldn't follow and he
couldn't even reach them think of like a
small child into a bookstore and a sort
of dark you know the books are there you
can't make them out but there's there's
real wisdom there there's something
explaining what's going on and very
occasionally you manage to stumble the
the greatest minds the human species can
produce manages to just get one minor
one from the bottom shelf and you come
up with with the equals mc-squared you
come up with
how could it be five simple symbols e/m
squared squared an equal scientist two
parallel lines and that explains why the
Sun burns that explains why the earth is
warm it explains how that horrible bombs
were exploded over Japan in 1945 it
explains also what's going to happen to
the earth in the future because far far
in the future our Sun will run out and
the earth will escape and end up in a
black hole I mean like that and all of
that is prefigured by this equation five
little simple how could that be it's
just stunning
einsteinium his views on religion were
sort of subtle he didn't believe in an
interventionist God who would answer
prayers but he did believe what he
called the old one which was not just a
force a general vague sort of
touchy-feely force but a very very
complex complicated thing that very
carefully set things up with this
equation and a few other things that we
hadn't discovered yet and was out there
waiting he loved it he only had twenty
years in which he was at his peak there
are about 25 26 years getting ready he
started doing good work when he was 26
if he had died at age 24 or 25 he would
have been mourned by his younger sister
who adored him and by his parents of
course especially his mother but it
wouldn't have been that important he
would have been a guy with potential was
a bit of a wise aleck in school of one
or two friends loved him that was it but
and by 46 he was the greatest physicist
that Europe had seen probably ever at
the level of Isaac Newton or higher and
then unfortunately his health was good
he was a sturdy fellow people who ever
went boating with him remarked when took
off his sweatshirt he looked good didn't
work out but he was a muscly guy I think
it was sort of like bohemian
Berlin in the 1920s he was in good shape
he lived into his seventies he only died
in 1955 and the last 30 years were sad
because what he had tried to do with
great success before just ended I think
it was Gene Kelly I won so an interview
with him he said the curse of being a
dancer is that when you're 17 or 18 you
don't know anything but you the machine
is perfect but you're 25 26 the machine
is very good and you're beginning to
learn something 30 35 you really know a
lot and the machine is it's okay if you
workout and then your 40s and after you
really know what it is to dance but the
machine won't operate
Einstein had 20 years and I'll talk
about
very beginning of those of those 20
years hell of a thing it was also an
honor to work with them to study
Einstein as his the introducer said I've
tried at Oxford for a number of years
Cambridge University in England is
famous for producing Nobel laureates
Oxford is great for producing snobbery
the put-downs at dinner tables and the
little digs and remarks they're they're
very good at but one thing I found is
that the people who specialize in
Einstein and often in even the theories
he came up with later have a certain
modesty it's sort of like if you're a
sports reporter you can maybe make some
fun of somebody they're a klutz but
you're having fun with Michael Jordan
he's like hold back
you're just you're nice and easy so it
was a real pleasure to be to be near him
the underlying idea of equals equals MC
squared is surprisingly easy to say the
the essence of it is just the very top
here e equals M if well here's a little
bit of em they're just equals I'm leave
out the C squared for a moment and what
it says is that energy equals mass B for
energy I'm firm s imagine that there's
like all the mass that there is over
here and all the energy there is over
here the massive stuff like rocks or
ballot papers or the Florida peninsula
or something or the earth itself just a
salad a pen is a bit of math there's all
this mass and over here there's
different types of energy electrical
electrical energy and wind energy and
sea energy and all that sort of stuff
and before 1905 before Einstein nobody
believed that they were connected
they're totally separate he found that
there was a bridge linking between them
and when you're in high school you learn
equations her everybody knows what
equations are equations are things that
teachers scream at you if you get wrong
the equations are things you have to
memorize when you get home I said no no
no an equation is a living vivid thing
for him the equal sign was propels
imagine a fiber optics to was like
particular teaching information pulsing
back and forth he found in 1905 you take
what's in Parratt of mass it shoots over
it can become energy and even better you
can take like solid energy you can take
energy raw energy light beams and stuff
and you think squeeze it down pops back
and become solid mass and he show that
both were true it's incredible now
that's a that's an easy enough idea and
a lot of people think ok I'll read a
book on relativity and find out more
about it but probably about that is that
it goes in one ear and out the other
many many people have tried to read
books on relativity
some of them were total hacks it's you
could so understand a full of books
didn't work but one of the popularized
accounts in relativity was written by
Albert Einstein and you still can't take
it in I mean nobody's going to know more
science than the nine Stein another
popular ice book on relativity was
written by Bertrand Russell who got the
Nobel Prize for Literature I pride
myself in my writing skills but I am NOT
virgin Russell so what did they do wrong
and I was thinking about and I was
thinking about it and I realized that
were I fly a lot I do business
consulting it's mine also you know just
kind of interesting stuff especially
like quite a motive work so I live in
England and I fly to Detroit a lot and
on the airplanes I Augie set out from
Heathrow with the best of intentions I
have really thoughtful worthy books
books which if I read them will expand
my mind and then usually last a little
bit after the the televised BBC news so
that when lunch is served and after that
I can't concentrate on the books but
what I can always concentrate on our
letters like if we can't can't read us
Steinbeck novel you can read Steinbeck's
letters gossip sometimes even People
magazine and things like that
because there's something inherent in us
as human beings were fascinated by
people so that got me to think a little
bit you can tell a profound story in
terms of people instead of ordinary
people because we're interested in that
we are default we don't find that hard
to do math is hard for most people some
people find it beautiful and easy like
like music but it's hard for most people
that people come very very easily and
then I thought of the name of the rose
my sister Audrey I think it was us told
me that I should read this book and I
said what's it about she said Oh a
medieval of Latin and flat
philosophy I said that doesn't sound the
sexiest of topic she said it's actually
Sherlock Holmes in the Middle Ages that
I could do because you can identify with
Sherlock Holmes you know that sort of
thing and also you won't be scared at
any moment you might find something
familiar you might find a friend there
others gonna be Sherlock Holmes there's
gonna be a Watson character that's gonna
be a baddie he'll uses ingenuity you
have some some way of orienting yourself
in and finding where you are so I
thought well what could orient us among
equals mc-squared
let's check and I tried it out with some
of my students at Oxford and I tried it
out with conversations with friends and
I tried it out with a lot of taxi
drivers in London occasionally my wife
would say maybe you don't have to give
them the whole story now while we're
just driving for shopping and I realised
that what really really works
to treat the equation as something
suitable for biography I had an image of
a wedding photograph where there's like
the happily married couple and then
there's the parents and the ancestors
around and I thought if it's a biography
you know where you are with the
biography there's got to be section on
the ancestors where did it come from it
was gonna be a section on the birth you
know our hero enters the world and then
you wonder did have a dysfunctional
childhood and then have it what happens
when it grows up what does the lead to
legend become so that was going to be my
my generating idea I've just have a
biography and that once that idea came
the book pretty much wrote itself it's
very very entertaining so how the
interesting thing is how to summarize
that I can you don't want to summarize
the whole book so I thought what I might
do is take highlights from the different
parts so I'll take mentions some of the
highlights from the first part where I
have the ancestors what are these
underlying concepts where did the II
come from where did the M come from what
is the seem a that's a funny letter so
I'll just give you some samples of those
and then I'll talk about how that
swooped into Einstein's brain in 1905 a
little bit about Einstein and then I'll
talk about what it led to later the the
race for the time of Baum in World War 2
we know that the Allies had the atomic
bomb first but it's often forgotten
Germany came very very close up until
1941 1942 they were well ahead of the of
the Western powers of the Allied powers
and on d-day a lot of them the Allied
forces have Geiger counters because
they're seriously worried about
radioactive weapons and it really was a
close friend thing as well mention and
then the equation goes on it explains
all sorts of little things the the red
exit signs you see in movie houses or
work by equals mc-squared
because they can't be plugged into the
electrical supply because if there's a
fire they would they would work and
there's this autonomous force mass is
being turned into energy
those little connection between the mass
from the energy realm there's a
radioactive gas floating inside every
little red exit sign you've seen in a
movie house and part of it is just going
out of existence it's a it's stranger
than science fiction there's mass there
there's mass there and then it vanishes
it doesn't just like get smaller go into
it vanishes it is not there anymore what
comes out as a flash of energy and we
notice and say oh yeah there's the exit
sign or the sign to the toilet or
something but it's happening it also
happens under our feet keeping the
planet warm it happens in the
keeping the earth warm it happened in
the creations of the galaxy so I'll talk
about that a little bit okay let me
start with the ancestors III begin the
story of love wasa to try to get across
this notion of mass I thought well I
could summarize like the essence of the
chapter the essence of the chapter out
mass is that all the parts of types of
mass in the universe are interconnected
if you were to take this book or a table
and burn it and just have like cinders
and dust go around have a pile of ashes
and you wait every little bit don't
forget anything put a huge giant plastic
bag around the room and collect
everything it would weigh exactly as
much if you burn a log you think I'll
disappear so just a little bit of ashes
weigh the smoke take it all just play
the film backwards
it weighs exactly as much no no mass is
created or destroyed that was there that
was the view of Lavoie see 170 hundreds
and one of the ways he proved that was
he decided to treat his new wife to a
French people can be really wild and
romantic and he just got married
my name is treating them his wife too
she would let her be part of his work
and what he decided to do I suppose I
can mention this for a mixed audience in
their living room of their flat of their
apartment in Paris he got a piece of
metal and he put it inside a glass
container and he said honey we're gonna
watch it rust and that's what they did
for day after day and week after week
it's this irrational exuberance that
people like a wild for and after he they
watched it rust
she was it's great advantage in this pre
feminist culture she was allowed to be
part of this experimented there's
pictures you can find in her quite neat
black ink uh drawings of the metal as a
bus it's not the most exciting pictures
I've seen but it gets there anyways
after they had let it rust for a while
and they heated it up a little bit to
speed up the rusting they weight it now
the question is if you take a piece of
metal and let it rust think of the
underbody of a car like the defender of
the belly of a car right you let it rust
is it gonna weigh more than when it
started so it's gonna weigh the same or
will it weight will it weigh less will
it be less weight so they weighed it
think of an answer in your head
more the same or less they weighed it
and it weighs more right if you take a
rusty panel on a car and weigh it when
it's rusty that have waited before it
weighs more when it's rusty the reason
is it's rusty because oxygen from the
air
swoops down and joins with the joins
with the metal you know metals they go
rusty because they they mix with the
oxygen
Paris oxide right the this the soils in
um in Alabama or Georgia are red for for
that reason our blood is red for that
reason
so it takes weight out of the air and I
love watch they found that if you put a
piece of metal like a car panel or from
a cab or something that and you weigh it
after it's rusted it seems to have
gained weight but if you measure the air
that had been around it if you weigh
that he had very very sensitive balances
that weighs less you know how much at
less it weighs exactly as much as the
metal gained so it's a perfect balance
it's very interesting the problems of aw
c8 aside from the unbelievable tedium of
what conversation at his house must have
been like if that was this honeymoon
think what it was like several years
later into the marriage okay he was
really into weighing input and output
analyses so he at one point there
weren't enough taxes being collected
among the poor people of France so he
built a wall around a Paris a big wall
he was one of the administrators it was
like the Berlin Wall was a time of costs
the equivalent of billions of dollars
and I mean it was like six foot high and
very thick and there were guards and
stuff the French people hated it because
you had to pay tax was going through and
in 1789 we know about the besties being
torn down but four days before the bus D
was torn down this wall was torn down
and think how hard that is to do sort of
like remember the fervor nineteen eighty
nine when people were attacking the
Berlin Wall it was like that people were
frantic they used the equivalent of
crowbars hammers tearing it with their
fists and Lavoie say had made a terrible
enemy Marat the the famous revolutionary
because a few years earlier my right had
invented something like a thermal camera
for measuring heat patterns rising from
things at one point he trained it on
Benjamin Franklin's bald head in Paris
Franklin was the American ambassador
there and I said look I have this
wonderful device and Lavoie they said
nothing happened Marat was furious he
went into hiding he became a
revolutionary a few years later come the
revolution Marat as you know was big in
the and the equivalent of the assembly
he had it in for um forever love RCA he
explained that he was an enemy of the
people he had made a wall that was going
to strangle us and in a few years later
at one of the most difficult points of
the French Revolution Lavoisier was
taken to prison and it was very very sad
he was in this prison he was in this
room at the edge of a long hallway he
knew that there was only going to be a
sham trial he could see the stars at
night among the dome of an astronomical
don't nearby this this big observatory
in Paris and he wrote letters he wrote
letters to the night before he died he
wrote to his wife and he wrote to
various other people and at the trial oh
by the way there's a famous saying that
the the French revolutionary judge said
the revolution has no need for
intellectuals first of all the judge
never said that that was a invented
later you a lot of the documents from
the time survived and I looked into them
at the British Library and a pair in um
in London and also some some research in
Paris and what happened he was just
treated as a because he headed the taxes
a Thor 'ti before the Revolution he was
hated for that they hated him for
running the wall and look about it his
experiment with the rusting metal what
comes in balances what comes out at all
balances and he was it was like he was a
fetishist to come back he did the same
thing with the wall so when he did it
was the piece of metal inside his living
room it created this immortality the
greatest chemists of the 18th century
but when you did it with the wall around
Paris come on guys we don't have enough
cats revenues let's very carefully
measure what's coming in the money and
peasants coming in could be like the
oxygen molecules coming in when he did
they had to kill them he was fairly
brave on the on the scaffolding and it
turns out that the rope spear shortly
thereafter was also taken to the same
scaffolding on the what's now the
plaster Lacan court for a Concorde and a
resolution and was that's a story of M
so what I do in that chapter is you're
reading the story about the sky
Lavoisier and like it's it's sort of not
it maybe it's not exactly a cliffhanger
but you wonder you know will will the
rust be more or less in wake Siewert
we're as excited as the Hina's wife or
other honeymoon will he will Marat die
in time to not be able to kill him how's
he going to defend himself against that
wall around Paris if somebody came in
the middle of your reading the chapter
then you say what's going I say oh
there's this guy here's this thing about
like balancing things and I'm interested
in about the wall about Paris and they
say why and you you want to finish this
chapter but you go back and you explain
to them oh oh it's because he thought
that the conservation of mass was a
fundamental of that look what you're
doing you're explaining the science
without ever having learned the science
I found them
popular science books are often very
difficult for people who are thoughtful
people but who aren't trained in science
because I treat you like a child we have
very simple emotions everybody's nobly
aspiring for something but here you feel
the full range of what la vache was
doing you're focusing on the story but
to understand the story you naturally
have
to get the signs there you finish that
chapter and you understand okay
conservation of mass everything balances
if um if I were to I won't do it but if
I were to throw this water onto the
floor and you measure the carpet very
very carefully it would be heavier by
the exact amount here no it wouldn't be
because some of the water would have
evaporated if you measure the weight of
the air the little bit of water vapor
they've gone up and add it to the weight
of the carpet it would be exactly the
same weight as the water when you start
it very very impressive that's the
notion of conservation of mass other
people did conservation of energy people
thought that the world was divided into
two parts in 1919 Oh to 1904 people's
left that's it there's two parts there's
mass and there's energy near the twain
shall meet
and the 1905 was this wonderful year for
Einstein he put him together that's when
he saw there was a connecting bridge or
that fiber-optic tube between the two of
them he almost didn't make it he almost
gave up he was a good student did
despite the reports that everybody talks
about the the famous line that you would
never amount to anything it was reported
by um in a document that Einsteins
sister had a younger sister Masha who he
we really love she adored him when he
first started teaching at a university
nobody came except for his best friend
Michelle and his sister Masha studying
of course advanced theoretical physics
anyways she wrote a memoir of what was
like to grow up in the Einstein
household which is a lovely memoir and
many of the stories come from there and
there actually was a professor at his
high school
who said I'm Stein you'll never amount
to anything and was the guy who was
teaching a Greek grammar and as his
sister wrote she said and indeed my
brother never did become a famous
professor of Greek literature so they
had a kind of a Sarki sarcastic tone
Einstein when he was adult had a very
good temper he was very phlegmatic when
he was young sometimes he had carried
away it is no justification having
little sisters for doing that I speak as
being the youngest of a big family and
once he got a bowling ball and he threw
it at her head and he was remember he
was in pretty good shape it hit why you
need bouncing off her head and as she
wrote years later this shows it's very
important to have the thick skull if you
wish to be the sister of a famous
physicist so the family had this really
lovely attitude and so he was a
prankster he was a joker he was a smart
aleck in class when there were good
teachers he really loved it he responded
well he dropped out of high school he's
famous for everything on that but he
only did that because the family his
family
they'd been electrical contractors in
Germany and probably out of an time
they didn't get a certain main contract
so I Stein's father and mother and the
uncles who they all work together went
to Italy because they thought it would
be a fairer country as indeed it was at
that time and I was lonesome he missed
his parents he missed his his sister so
he left he just left at age about 15 so
as a dropout that dropout with the
reason and then he applied to go to
university in Switzerland there was a
place that would take if you didn't have
high school diploma and he took the
entrance exams and it fairly well with
math and science and decent in French
but in some other things he wasn't that
good so he went to a remedial high
school for a year and there was a
beautiful high school it was in the
northern of Swiss valleys in the town of
arrow if you haven't been there I
strongly recommend it it is much more
pleasant to be there than to be at
Lavoie phase experiment with the rust
it's a beautiful beautiful place there
is this double pincer movement going on
at the time of the French Revolution the
the two things happened one is the Jews
in Central Europe gradually became
liberated they were emancipated they
they didn't have to be serfs they were
and that was at the level of Einsteins
great-grandparents and that gradually
led Einstein s grandfather get a real
job
Einstein's parents get into electrical
contracting and Einstein himself study
at a good school so that was one thing
the liberation from the French
Revolution led to that Einstein being
free another sign for the French
Revolution was that all sorts of
nationalist authorities in Europe
reacted against that they they didn't
want French imperialism to come they
thought hey if the French people have a
right to their democratic equal rights
shouldn't wait and in a Switzerland an
educator named pesto lazy became very
important a lot of our child center
education in American presidential
debates comes from pesto lazy and his
prime school the one that was his magnet
school of the 8th of the 19th century
was in the town of arrow so Einstein
lucked out it probably was the best high
school for somebody like him in the
world at that time there were none in
America that level and was wonderful it
also helped that he stayed was a
headmaster who had several daughters one
of whom was two years older than
Einstein and was his first true love as
the sign of the true love is he remarked
to his mother she even did his laundry
for a young German Swiss boy this was
that this was above me on the call of
duty
anyways he got into University and he
did fairly well at university again the
problem was he thought really hard about
things but
Stan time-wasters and one of the
professor's there was the time-waster
had old lecture notes crinkly yellow
paper that was twenty years old thirty
years old forty years old
Einstein couldn't bear that and he
refused to call that professor of
professor Weber he calls him mr. Weber
hair Weber as a result when Einstein
graduated in his sub group there were
four graduates three of them got letters
of recommendation from Weber and they
went on to university assistantships the
other one was Einstein Weber wouldn't do
anything for him near the front of the
book I have this some a letter that has
been dug up from Einsteins father
writing in 13th of April 1901 to a
famous professor in Leipzig saying
esteemed care professor my son Albert is
22 years old he feels profoundly unhappy
with his present lack of position he
feels he's getting off the tracks with
his career he is I've taken the liberty
of turning to you with the humble
request and the father went on and on
saying could you give my son a job but
don't mention it to him his egos too
fragile he didn't use the word ego no
answer from that professor ever came
back and I said didn't get the job oh by
the way fifteen years later that
professor nominated Einstein for the
Nobel Prize which is pretty good
so 1901 past 1902 1903 I Stein was think
of that the sort of kid who's like
bright smart aleck aids University and
you're kind of you know kind of popular
used to go to the coffee shops in Zurich
people hung out with them he was funny
he was quick-witted he the time of his
life when he was happiest was 1920s
Berlin under von Maur it was it was he
was good for that but you have this
great potential and some of your other
friends do kind of boring jobs to go off
to Wall Street her go after Silicon
Valley and you're gonna do great and
wonderful things but nothing happens
well next year you're gonna write this
terrific say you're just gonna be
terrific cause you can see deeper than
other people still nothing happens he
was 24 he was 25 he worked six days a
week at the Patent Office and Bern
Switzerland six days a week means he
gets out at 6 or 7 p.m. on Saturday
there was one science library in the
town it was closed then he couldn't even
see the latest scientific papers because
it wasn't open on Sunday and he wrote to
his sister he was slipping behind this
boy chip with the great potential
nothing was happening and he made
friends his best friend was just a young
man named Michel Italian Swiss guy and
they'd go for long walks and they would
talk about philosophy and I said always
wanted to unite different parts of the
universe he believed that vision of the
library I think haunted him his whole
life long there was something out there
things that seemed separate and
disappeared on the surface
if you look really really close there
should be a way of getting them together
and even tried some papers when he was
23 or 24 some essays he wrote and they
weren't very good they did they weren't
important then in 1905 something
happened he wrote about four or five
papers at least three of them were
worthy of the Nobel Prize and in fact
when he got his Nobel Prize later it
wasn't for the theory of relativity it
was for the photoelectric effect which
is we won't go into that but it's
fundamental to the runnings of the
Internet it discusses ways in which
fiber-optic tubes work and can interact
make electrical machinery work so there
was just one of his one of his minor
papers that year was like the basis for
the internet and and worthy of a Nobel
Prize wasn't even his top stuff he was
on a roll you know that sort of thing
you many of us have the feeling you have
a problem of business or in writing or
something
he's just an emotional problem with
friends you can't quite work it out you
take a shower you go for a run or just
wake up the next morning and you solve
it that's us solving our ordinary
problems I sign had been like that for
ten years he'll eight years later he
said that if he hadn't had those years
in his early 20s away from a university
away from a formal job he absolutely
wouldn't have been he wouldn't have been
Einstein he would been forced to publish
or perish he would have done the current
ongoing research he would have done
great papers on agricultural chemistry
he wouldn't have been able to just
quietly think as I trying to get a
funding grant these days I'm going to
think for several years about what time
and space might be i've never published
anything and my professors thought i was
a bit of a lazy person but trust me it
couldn't be done right he had a drawer
in his Patent Office which he calls his
department of theoretical physics and
whenever his patent supervisor was away
he would take out papers and try to
scribble some stuff and when the patent
supervisor a fellow named Haller came by
Einstein would put in the door and slam
it closed that's why I called it his
drawer of theoretical physics and 1905
it really all came together Hillel the
great rabbi once said if you have a fire
it's burning at a certain brightness if
you take one of the Browns away and put
her up by itself in the open air it'll
burst it go into into brighter flames
because it gets all the fresh air coming
in from outside and that was Einstein
1905 he was well that was it happened of
course Hillel also went on to say that
after a while that Brad you've taken
bias it's I the little log it'll die
down it'll be a called darkened Ember
while the main fire still burning and
that was
sign after 1926 but boy in those 20
years he had a run it uh I don't know
what would we do if we had that trade
off knowing you could have 20 years like
that and then another 20 or 30 years of
the ad where people sort of scoff at you
people didn't know anything would love
you I mean at Princeton in the 1950s
bobby-soxers er frat boys would think he
was incredible but working physicists
didn't respect them didn't bother him he
was convinced he was right he'd been
right before he was convinced to be
right again anyways but back to the
early day so he wrote these several
papers and he also wrote a paper on the
special theory of relativity by the way
the Swiss authorities
I suppose define what bureaucracy
bureaucratic is he applied for a job at
the University of the following year he
submitted in his application forms the
theory of relativity they turned him
down because the pagination and layout
was not properly done made many
apocryphal stories a creature around
someone like Einstein but this one I
checked from the original sources
actually or all of them in the book
somebody who is at that faculty meeting
who was appalled that his colleagues
were such numbskulls and sticking
sickening to the thing he'll supply for
a part-time high school teaching job
further south in Switzerland and again
he was turned down despite having a
relativity as his application form and
indeed he never did become known as a
famous high school teacher in southern
Switzerland about two or three year
anyway so he wrote the theory relativity
and there's something missing something
he wasn't quite sure what he just had
this feeling of odd uncomfortableness
and then he woke up and he had it and
about four or five weeks later he sent
in a very very brief four-page paper to
this a popular a very important journal
in uh in Germany and that had equals
mc-squared that has a conclusion he did
use different letters at the time if you
ever see an autographed copy of e equals
mc-squared from 1905 it's not true he
used he used different letters but that
was the principle that energy and mass
were interchangeable like that the full
concept wasn't clear his head but but he
was in that direction so wonderful thing
so that was there and so the goal he had
had for years of uniting the different
parts of the universe it come true mess
over here love wisely at all those
people
energy over here Ben Franklin's
electricity all those sort of things
there was actually a sizzling connection
even more if I simply said if I took
away the C squared no C squared right
energy equals mass that's not too
exciting you take say the mass of a pen
and maybe you burn it and what would you
tours take take a pound of coal and burn
it
might keep a room warm for a few hours
or something but it's not a great deal
it turns out C is the speed of light
which is very very fast 670 million
miles an hour the space shuttle a
Concorde would travel it maybe 1,200
miles an hour the speed of light the
speed of sound is bus
as I speak now the death sound bubbles
from my mouth are reaching your ears and
they're travelling about 700 miles an
hour which is again pretty impressive
a high wind is 50 or 80 miles an hour
700 mile an hour hurricane I mean I
don't think has ever been something like
that on the surface of the earth
so that's blasting its years luckily
only a small amount is coming out of the
mouth now well light is a million times
faster 670 million million miles an hour
it's really incredibly fast so C is a
big number and when you square it it's
even bigger it's it's hard to imagine
and what Einstein was saying is that if
you take a small amount of mass say a
pound of coal or something if you burn
it it's not important but if you totally
convert it into energy squeeze it
through the equation something
interesting happens to find out how much
energy comes out exactly to the exact
decimal point you take the mass weigh it
exactly multiply it by the square of the
speed of light which is this
unbelievable number trillions upon
trillions about trillions and that's
what comes out so instead of it being
masses here and energies here in a
little straight line it's masses here in
the room it accelerates it ramps up at
an unbelievable rate the city of
Hiroshima was destroyed by this we know
that the atomic bomb was a big bomb
almost all of that battement weighed
about 9,000 pounds was casing and steel
on the outside and cordite detonators
and they were on radar systems in the
bomb it exploded about 1,800 feet and
was sending little radar signals it was
centered on a hospital directly below it
and when it got to 800 feet it exploded
oh there was only about 45 or 50 pounds
of uranium inside the bomb enough that
only a little bit of that uranium
exploded and I was yet only a teeny
teeny amount perhaps some a few grams
less than the weight of this tip of this
pen was converted from mass into energy
much less in this way and that was
enough just that little smidgen of metal
smidgen of metal energy that had been
stored inside those atoms from before
the earth was created over four and a
half billion years they've been squeezed
inside when they came out the
electrostatic force
propelled them apart and that energy
multiplied by the dead mass multiplied
by the speed of light produced the
energy
that destroyed this entire city if
you've ever seen those giant like yellow
painted caterpillar equipment that can
sort of you know bulldozer says just
push up a street a little bit I mean
that's that's really powerful and strong
imagine how many of those equipments of
those machines you would need to like
push up maybe 20 or 30 or 40 or 50 of
the streets in Princeton meant to them
all operating the same time and then
imagine giant cranes just sort of
smashing down all the buildings around
here not just for one or two blasts but
can you imagine the amount of energy
that be used for all that all that came
from less than this and it happened in a
fraction of a second the light from that
was so powerful I checked with the US
Naval Observatory where the word how the
solar system was arranged that some of
the light hit the moon and bounced it
off and bounced back to earth not a lot
but enough to notice as it's really
really something so that's what it's led
to so what can we do now we've had I've
talked about the background of this the
back one of the things I'm strands idea
let's see let's do some sort of
participatory democracy voting now which
I believe is a very popular thing in
America in the late latter part of in
November in the year 2000 and even later
I can talk a little bit more about the
people who opened up the atom or I could
talk about the atomic bomb project a
little bit which I drew the time I found
project a little bit and then and then
we'll talk about it and then we'll
finish off with a survey we'll finish
off with a little survey of the universe
and after that just a superstone of
Brandi okay we'll do the atomic bomb
project a bit when I was writing the
book I thought how could he do that
fresh it's a terrific story but many
people are vaguely aware yeah people
knew how to open up the atom unless they
had a powerful energy come out the
electrical charges from the center of an
atom
Einstein had foreseen it years before
and we knew that America with this giant
technological power clearly would
succeed Germany is like a small middle
sized European country now America is
this giant Colossus we have aircraft
carriers and stuff like that clearly
there's no competition it seemed very
very easy in fact at the time is very
different in 1939 science was not much
respected in America all good grad
students had to go to to Europe for for
their work in the way that many
third-world grad students now come to
come to the United States for their work
there was a professor I had as the
University of Chicago who in 1939 needed
to get a an important part for an
experiment leading up to this sort of
work he went to a local gas station and
he had to pay like
96 cents to an old get an old disused
rusted gas pump handle he could break
apart for those finally machine Springs
a few years later at Los Alamos with a
part was needed at one point they
thought they would need 80 pounds of
pure gold to sort of keep in some of the
explosions in atomic bounce and bounce
the neutrons back the requisition went
out to Fort Knox and came back about a
week later a that story showed two weeks
later the gold actually came a Charlotte
server tells that story she was working
in the library at Los Alamos said and
she put the that gold in a little box
inside a little um paper bag and she'd
say to people that came to the library
Oh
would you would you big strong fella
just move my tiny little paper bag and
they'd lift it up it weights it's
heavier than light it's denser than lead
okay so that's a change she also said if
any of you worked with the government if
you put an out a request for a new
typewriter you wouldn't get it back in
two weeks or take a lot longer so in
1938 1939 science wasn't respected in
America and the army was almost nowhere
the US had under two divisions Germany
at that time had over a hundred pretty
well-equipped divisions the US Army was
about 17th in the world well well well
below the level of Belgium there was
just there was no skill there was no
base that there weren't any there
weren't that many good engineers there
is no military industrial complex which
had no went to extremes later there was
none of that in place Germany was way
out in front and the Allied intelligence
got very seriously worried one of the
main ingredients when the main
constituents needed for the bottom was
what's called heavy water and it needs a
lot of electricity to make it and is
being made at a factory in Norway about
80 miles 90 miles west of ozlowe I
visited that Factory and outlet
intelligence thought they had to destroy
that Factory because otherwise the
Germans would have that constituent for
their bomb you use heavy water and it
allows you to really to really intensify
the the radioactivity of the of these
elements so the the Brits sent in a
30-30 young man from the Russian know
what I remember reading is British 30
British airborne regiment paratroopers
went in and some of me thought oh wow
these must be tough guys kind of
superheroes commandos from the movies
but I did a bit more research and a lot
of the biographies of these oh by the
way well 30 of these guys died they
didn't get within 10 miles of the
factory they either died in crash
landings or the throats were slit or
they were tortured by the Germans but
they didn't know that of course and I
researched a bit of their backgrounds
and many of them were about 18 years old
19 years old
someone like
the nine comps the net Commission
officers may be 21 or 22 a lot of them
had grown up in Paddington in West
London so they were sort of Irish
English tough working-class they'd grown
up in the depression I I found the not
the brother but somebody from that exact
same area who still live now who had
been in the forces and didn't go and I
said what was it like then he said you
have no concept I said no look come on I
can corrupt that rich in America I have
some concepts you have no concept there
was something we didn't have in our
houses which you can't imagine not
having what could it be what do you
think they didn't have in their house
does anybody want to guess they a key
they couldn't afford it front door key
how's that the street had to share a key
how's that right see III thought eyelet
running water no no a key could you
imagine that I can't imagine that I'm
something like the book Angela's Ashes
gives a little hint of that so that was
these guys and they were being trained
in the British Army the airborne
regiment they were tough guys these were
not you know poncey a wimp to the sort
that Mel Gibson makes fun of in his
movies these were these real guys until
the morning that they flew to to Norway
they they were doing a tough training in
Scotland but I thought they were in for
a paratroop competition with the Yanks
they started gonna be sort of jolly fun
you know this you know we tell the eggs
but then you have a good beer altogether
okay maybe a terrible beer at room
temperature for something like that
suddenly that afternoon they were told
that they were actually going to be
going into Norway at night in
nazi-occupied Europe the guys didn't
have a clue they went in in two planes
with these big cargo gliders towed
behind gliders that weren't like them
our gliders now which is these very you
know small things they're more like
small cargo planes without an engine and
the pilot of one of them was from the
Australian Air Force and he never he
didn't know that much about snow your he
was caught with his terrible delivers
about three or four in the morning he
was over Norway's there were German
troops below he was icing up when he
went high
icing up was gonna make his glider crash
so he came down low they were going by
this giant mountains called the barren
mountains about 120 miles west of Oslo
west-southwest the the iron inside those
mountains was messing up his compass and
the wind was quite at night snowstorms
in Norway was blowing his thing all over
said okay go higher but then you iced up
he was caught the crash land at 12 him
crash lens at about half the troops to
hide when they landed a few of the
others tried to get out the again these
were London boys all right tough London
boys think of 19 year old kids right
maybe some from fairly tough
neighborhoods today that
morning they thought they were in
training for a paratrooper competition
to competition with the Yanks that
evening a 3 in the morning they were
staggering through the dark the ones
that survived injected themselves with
morphine against the pain and a lot of
them took amphetamines so the ones who
weren't injured at all and they were
turned in either by their most of the
Norwegians were very very brave in
anti-german but unfortunately were a
very small number who are collaborators
so they returned in either by local
collaborators or local police or by
German troops and they all died the the
fellow who controlled this this drop
from Special who controlled the
intelligence was a guy named Harvey
Jones I look into his biography also he
had been a few years before he'd been an
astronomy student at Oxford he was just
in his 20s at now he was in his early
30s and he had this incredible dilemma
what do you do next do you send in more
troops I mean a few years before they'd
be the sort of jolly conversation you
have over dinner with friends right ha
there's a moral dilemma but now pretty
bear to do it plus he wasn't going
himself so he did and he sent in six
Norwegians including one of them was a
plumber from Oslo one of whom is as well
and their legions are tougher than most
other human beings I've spent a while
there they they're very determined folks
and these guys went in and they they
blew up the factory they didn't blow up
the whole thing with a giant explosion
they managed with small place charges
all around it and they they blew up the
the key ingredient this heavy water that
dripped down and through the drains and
went down the mountain and stuff and it
was and they all managed to escape but
the Germans had extremely good civil
engineers and they managed to
reconstruct the factory and finally
later about a year later about 600
kilograms of this central fuel was being
taken back to Germany by the way after
the war Heisenberg this total lying
creep who after the words apologized and
pretended he hadn't meant anything and
hadn't done it and all that sort of
stuff after the war he was interrogated
by British authorities and he said you
know if we only had about 600 kilograms
more fuel we would have been able to
make it we would have been able to not
make a bomb but probably a radioactive
weapon just spray plutonium over the
city of London or over all those allied
emplacements in the in um in
northwestern France or earlier in
southeastern England anyways
600 but nobody knew that it was so that
important at the time but about 600
kilograms of the heavy water was going
to be taken from this Factory in Norway
back to Germany and there was only one
Norwegian commando left in the area all
the
it had to go and he was told destroy it
the only place to destroy it there about
12,000 German troops protecting it he
wasn't worried about most of the troops
he was worried by the specialized SS ski
troops and again the Norwegian
collaborators who could lead him in and
the Germans were very thorough they
firebombed in a pound all the huts
around there so that he couldn't be
living rough but he got into local town
and so there was one weak spot
the Train was a fuel we have to blow
down to both the boat would go over Lake
okay he said well you could blow up the
boat but of course he said you couldn't
do that because Norwegian women and
children took that boat it was a local
town I'm visited by there this thing the
memo came back to our V Jones I was on a
bus in Norway researching this and the
original memo of course haven't survived
because um you know you're here in
nazi-occupied Europe you you don't keep
the copies of what you tap out and I was
chatting about my visit there and
there's this really nice Norwegian guy
who is speaking I was speaking with and
he said oh yeah you know my my uncle was
the Telex the radio operator for these
guys he became later went to Harvard
after the war it's good place and became
a hydraulic engineer and he said yeah up
in the attic I think we have copies of
the old telex is he reconstruct a lot of
them shortly afterwards well they
weren't in Britain I checked very
thoroughly with the military historians
so this was great we stayed in touch got
access to that sort of stuff and the the
memo went back the the the the radio
message went back to London
what are you sure it's that important
are you sure it's that important I can
come here to kill write my own
compatriots what do you do it as I was
writing that I thought of this section
from Genesis where God told Abraham to
kill his son Isaac who he loved his only
son remember Abraham lifted his hand up
we sometimes think oh that means he was
going to do it all that means is he
lifts his hand up we don't know what was
in his heart but God stayed his hand
well in this case God didn't stay his
hand RV Jones in London said the
telegram Beck you have to do it and he
did now when a boat goes down in deep
water healthy young men can easily get
off but she goes go beyond you just
knock people to tie you frantically go
to the side so the German guards would
guarantee to live right the bad guys and
the people who died about 15 or 20
people were the ones either who were
polite or who were small right the older
people are the children and they drowned
but the heavy water the 600 kilograms of
it in the barrels went down down down in
the water cuz a wait wait they weighed
more than ordinary water and
he could not make even a radioactive
weapon after the war and it was just
exactly 600 kilos that Heisenberg missed
so was it worth it it's easy for us to
say you have course was worth it to stop
the weapon but the guy right there at
the moment it's a hell of a thing I was
really really struck by that okay we're
now approaching the edge I'm going to
have a sip of water and then finish it
off with a bit of a survey of how the
equation applies an ordinary life into
the whole universe it's wonderful to be
able to say sentences like that I mean I
really swear I'm gonna do some of this I
mean I liked working for the automotive
industry and it's it's fun and it's
there's all these neat stuff with fuel
cells and stuff coming on but how often
do you say after the water we're going
to survey the past and future of the
universe you remember I said that equals
mc-squared
goes in two directions mass can turn
into energy into a lot of energy it also
goes the other way if there's a lot of
energy and you squeeze it really really
squeeze it you can get a solid mass to
pop out imagine this room was stark
jet-black and I had a flashlight over
here and a flashlight over here and show
them together the beams would intersect
well we know that when the photons from
the beams hit there's just more light
you don't get solid chunks of rock
coming into existence doesn't happen if
those beams had high enough energy it
would well that one time when that
happened in our universe was in the
first about 1.8 seconds after the Big
Bang it actually the there was only pure
energy there there's only energy but it
was so intense and so powerful that when
it hit itself it began to solidify you
can say I'm speaking a bit
metaphorically into solid stuff again
I'm speaking metaphorically but it
turned from energy and to mass and all
the constituents in our bodies the
constituents of this water the hydrogen
and the oxygen the the carpet in one's
arm the the iron in one's blood all that
the the hair powder on Lavoisier in
France the the the microphone that
Clinton will wear as he gives his
various talks all the constituents of
that were created in solid were squeezed
out of energy in a core of the equation
fifteen billion years ago I didn't know
that detail but it follows what he had
seen in his head
I found that amazing in the same way I
found stunning when I was reading about
those those British commandos are the
ones who didn't make it into factory
these guys were scrambling up snowy
hillsides at night not knowing what was
going on because somebody 35 years
before
this sort of young German kid with a
sort of sense of humor and a sweet
younger sister had put together these
powerful thoughts they didn't know who
was controlling who's controlling our
lives in the same way what things will
we in our future be doing based on when
somebody else is thought of as a
terrific thought anyways so in the
survey of the universe energy gets
squeezed into mass and then solid mass
becomes gets formed after a while stars
galaxies things like that and a
particular things like our Sun and our
planet Earth without it equals
mc-squared
ours would be the so-called barren rock
just spinning empty just around the Sun
right just by itself but there's a lot
of thorium and uranium under our feet
and that stays warm because bits of it
exist exist exist an igloo into
non-existence they pop out of existence
stranger than any science fiction movie
and energy appears in their place these
scattered has I click click click when
you hear a Geiger counter buckle click
you're hearing each one in a sense as
equals mc-squared operation mass is
going to energy amplified in you here
it's interesting that Geiger is in the
book there's a man named Hans Geiger who
at a very clever way for detecting a
sounds so that's happening under our
feet the thorium and uranium are going
out of existence and popping into energy
and that heats us up the San Francisco
Bay was created you know as the land
masses were putting pushing apart
because of the heat underneath pushing
the plate tectonics pushing the surface
of the earth the Rocky Mountains the
Appalachians the the Himalayas all that
sort of stuff was happening like that
also the top of the earth would be
infertile
unless who were four equals mc-squared
in the Midwest and Ukranian in parts of
West Africa you have thick beautiful
fertile soil because volcanoes punched
up through the surface and gushed out
from deep inside the planet all these
beautiful gases and chemicals and
elements which led that filtered on it
became the structures of our soil
without that our planet would have been
barren maybe it'd be warm but it would
have been barren it's really really
really quite impressive and then humans
come across the story and we use that
idea equals mc-squared all the time in
our technology medical tracers often use
it chemotherapy for for cancer a PET
scans positive emission tomography I
think it's called also that's all equals
mc-squared finally little bits of mass
to blessing apart to entertain you can
detect to where exactly where it is
those are PET scans roughly or
chemotherapy where you take this mass
the energy sprays out very very exactly
you can get the dosage exactly right you
can
point it it was all so benevolent uses a
television set would not work without
four equals mc-squared if Warren four
equals MC squared because the electron
is not flat screen the electrons at the
back of the conventional television set
like those beautiful mecha computers the
electrodes come out and they go really
fast close to the speed of light and
they get heavier the mass is the energy
moving along roughly roughly is turning
into mass they get heavier pudgie ER
they actually get engineer's have to
take them to account when they build
their screens without that your TV would
always be out of focus every time you
see a sharp focused TV tube because of
equals mc-squared has been taken into
account via GPS a global positioning
satellite systems that you use for
hiking and navigation or something there
are they're speeding around us so fast
it's only about maybe twenty or forty
thousand miles an hour but it's a
substantial fraction of the speed of
light faster than us I mean it's it's
low compared to light but it's a lot
compared to us and so all these effects
that einstein noticed start adding up
every time you hold a gps receiver it
corrects the the mount that the
satellite is shifting out of accurate
position in accord with the equations
there were nine Stein's head so you're
holding like a little miniature model of
einstein's brain every time you hold the
gps receiver it goes on and on as I
mentioned those red glowing exit signs
and it's it's it's full of that sort of
stuff anyways and it also will apply to
our future because the Sun burns by mass
turning into energy wham wham wham wham
wham four million tons a second of
hydrogen are turned into energy they go
out of existence they're not there
anymore and it lights up lights up our
entire solar system Earth Jupiter Saturn
all Direction just fill up with light
you can see it as you know from from
billions billions billions and billions
as mr. Sagan too late lovely mr. segment
who said from that far away you can see
it for of course from other stars as we
can see other stars there's those
explosions inside our Sun there's a
young woman from England named Cecilia
Payne I have a chapter on her who first
can see that this might be the case she
couldn't do grad work in England cuz she
was a girl so she came to Harvard where
everybody would be nice and fair and she
realized that the Sun wasn't made of
iron this made many people have thought
in the early 1920s
it's kind of make sense the earth has a
lot of iron meteorites are higher in a
rocker stuff it was made of hydrogen and
that would allow equals mc-squared to
operate she was forced to suppress her
thesis she was allowed to publish her
thesis but had to say my conclusions are
no doubt false and the guys who made her
suppress her thesis a few years later
when the evidence came true King
showing she was definitely right a lot
of them took the credit and they never
allowed her to get proper position at
Harvard or Radcliffe
she was classified as equipment expense
her salary was equipment expense rather
than that of even a teaching instructor
but she had lovely revenge her revenge
was she was extremely kind to young
students and many of them have the
sweetest memories of her
nobody has those sweet memories of them
when the guy name was Anne in Brussels
not breaking the rest of the different
Russell the guys who suppress her she
also learned languages to entertain
herself as she got older her daughter
said she learned about fifteen or twenty
though her accent and Icelandic was
never really quite perfect and her
daughter became an astronomer and a
slightly more liberated post-war age and
they published papers together which I
thought was very very sweet so it's one
of the tough ladies in the book quite a
good revenge anyways the sonnet is
burning four million tons of hydrogen
each second out of existence not burning
into the ashes just it stops being there
and it becomes energy instead the mass
is turning to energy the Sun is big it's
been doing this for four and half
billion years but eventually it'll run
out about five billion years from now
the earth will look will get fried as
the sudden large is a little bit then
the Sun will shrink those are silver
processes but it'll really shrink and
there won't be enough mass left to keep
the earth in orbit you know if you have
a rock on a strange spin around okay you
let go that's gonna happen to the earth
about five billion years from now it's
gonna fly loose it'll fly loose through
our galaxy just this rock I don't know
would there be will there be intelligent
beings
still trying to do the count in Florida
not will there be anybody you're I
clocked underneath I mean you have no
idea maybe maybe our descendants of
whatever sort they might be are living
elsewhere maybe life will open what I
have no idea about this planet where all
this stuff happened we'll just be going
loose through the galaxy and I sign even
roughly four so our ultimate fate at the
center of seems most large galaxies most
galaxies there's a very large black hole
and the black hole was predicted to a
great extent in accord with Einstein's
later work and also with equals
mc-squared
it's that there's a chapter on that know
um when I was young I studied with this
distinguished L - really guys Chandra
Sekhar who I thought must have always
been 65 years old Kath when he was 19 he
first came up with the notion leading to
black holes he was from the south of
India and he was travelling from India
to Cambridge England crossing the
Arabian Sea and none of course of the
proper upper-middle class Brits would
speak to him because he was of the wrong
sort even tried to play with the kids
when they'd come up to him and the
parents would sort of pull the kids away
right because that was wrong well give
him a lot of time in his neck chair and
he thought and he thought and he thought
and he created this wonderful work he
later got the Nobel Prize for work that
was directly related to that it's
terrific fellow there's a satellite
overhead now which was launched to last
year called the Chandra and it
identifies things including photographs
from the very edge of black holes so
again he key prevailed
I found the book made me feel very very
good a number of people were crushed but
if they really really believed they
weren't crushed forever either history
was the medication or writing it was or
reading it could be all so anyways we've
left the earth floating loose in the
galaxy there's a black hole waiting at
the center and some time guarantee about
five billion years from now the earth
will get close to that black hole and
closer and closer and then that's it
it's gone and the story doesn't end
there the story goes that because
they're still solid mass in the universe
there's other stars and other bits and
stuff and I at the end of the book I
take the story all the way along to the
very very final end of time or almost
the end of the time and equals empty
squares collaborating there for me
that's one of the most powerful things
my father passed away when I was ten
years old and I was always deeply
touched by the notion of things that
survived he didn't survive but his
memory survived and what I do then what
my sisters do and and family and stuff
that that always means a lot and I
became fascinated when I studied math
and science the things can exist long
over long periods of time when the most
powerful politicians are those beautiful
pieces of wood are long decayed a two
plus two equals four was true in ancient
Mesopotamia was true five billion years
ago it'll be true when the earth goes
into the black hole that's always true
it wasn't a contacting my late father
it was just being aware of just making
contact when when you read a lovely book
and you realize that the person who
wrote it maybe died in the 1920s or was
a novel from a previous century it's
very beautiful
and you think of some other like the
nice gesture you wish to do to people
now that might survive on without you
being recognized that's okay but it
might lead to consequences just rippling
forward through time and I love the
notion of what Einstein saw that
beautiful library around right he saw
something that had always been true it
gave me the greatest pleasure to be able
to summarize some of that in a book and
that's what the book is thank you
if anybody has questions the theory of
relativity is a large special relativity
ated in 1905 is a big thing and about
five weeks later he actually came up
with the formula he used different
symbols he said if I use the symbol L it
changed later but actually Einstein
himself came up with the formula it was
about five weeks later and he wrote to
his friends saying I found this
wonderful consequence of my theory look
at this he was delighted with himself he
thought he even said that it might be
possible using radioactive soil such as
radium which Madame Curie was working
not in Paris and might be possible using
that to someday release some of this
energy though it was only a theoretical
possibility it's really something why
did he change the letters involved in
the formula bet I don't know I wonder if
he was using German letters versus Latin
letters or something that I really don't
know any other questions yeah the letter
C and why Einstein connected C to mass
and then why he why he squared it right
which is I mean it seems almost
impossible yet to you know to imagine
something that big yeah and then YC yeah
and then Y square right okay so that was
rough cuz those are I mean you hit on a
good point those are like the
theoretical essence of it in the first
draft of the book I just I stuck
I didn't know how much do I give the
pure science how much the stories and I
realized you don't have to decide it's
like a DNA strand or like we're chance
the the lovers the hands right together
they form the cathedral by the way if
you ever look closely at that beautiful
Rodin sculpture it's not this it's not a
right in the left hand it's a it's two
right hands you can only do that with a
couple you can't do it by yourselves
really a beautiful thought okay so why
is the sea in there the details really
do take a full chapter but roughly
roughly roughly Einstein felt that
there's some speeds which
always go faster that if this ovens
fastest and airplane can go now might be
a thousand miles an hour three thousand
miles an hour well if you have
afterburners and it's more streamlined
to more powerful engines you can always
go a little bit faster see is different
than that he felt that si was an utter
speed limit you could not go faster than
si it was just like that the explanation
will have to rest in the book but just
imagine that that's true and imagine
you're in a space shuttle and you're
getting trying to get close to this see
the speed of the speed of light and
you've got in your engine but you'll
never quite catch up with it think of
like fraternity boys maybe at Princeton
of the 1950's triangle squeeze inside a
phonebook their faces are pushed up
against you know the edge and stuff
imagine somebody on earth is spraying
energy ingenuity like pumping energy
give me energy Scottie you know beam
beaming in energy and they're trying to
go faster and faster but you can't you
can't go any faster so the energy that's
being pumped into you it can't go to
making you faster what is gonna do
there's like think of over inflating a
blue mm-hmm again this is only
metaphorically speaking if C is the
ultimate speed limit if you can't go
faster than that now somebody pumps
energy in Jesus Khan okay so go faster
it has to come out and some other way it
comes out as mass so that's why again
roughly speaking C is so important y
squared is important again it's sort of
technical and I think it's carried out
fairly clearly in the book but I can
give one example one experiment that
don't that might make it clear a little
bit if you've ever driven a car on an
icy road if you're an experienced driver
you know do not lock your wheels right
controlled controlled braking but if you
ever lock your wheels if you see a kid
lock the wheel they skid well it turns
out that's skid the distance of the skid
is a measure of how much energy there is
when you're driving the car long if
you're going at 20 miles an hour and you
and you lock the wheels and you skid you
go a certain distance well it turns out
if you're going at 40 miles an hour
twice twice as fast and you lock your
brakes and skid you don't go twice as
far
giel four times as far if you're going
at 60 miles an hour three times as fast
you don't go three times as far you go
nine times as far and there's a a Dutch
physicist in the early 1700s who is very
empirical he got clay and mud there's a
lot of clay in the Netherlands and he
got little brass balls and he would drop
a one into the clay and he would see if
it goes if it weighs a certain amount it
goes down to a certain speed it goes in
a certain depth think of like trusting a
little BB or 22 pellet into balsa when
it goes in a certain distance if he got
a ball that
went down three times as fast roughly
roughly it would go in nine times as
deep as three times is eight nine time
so everybody began to think that a real
measure of energy isn't just after the
energy that an object carries isn't just
a matter of what the velocity is it's a
matter of the square of the velocity so
for at least two centuries before
Einstein people were very familiar with
the notion that it's a way to measure
energy imagine this isn't C but good as
V is like you take the mass of something
you don't just multiply it by the
velocity you know it isn't just your car
you multiply it by the square of the
speed of your car the square of the
speed of the ball going down so
everybody was really used to e equals MV
squared whatever the velocity is U
square the velocity that gives you the
energy and it has well again again
speaking roughly if the maximum possible
velocity is C if V gets higher and
higher message of computerized counter
I'm gonna get a faster faster the
numbers getting higher and higher but
the top one is C and again this is only
metaphorical that's the maximum energy
anything can ever happen
does that get it a bit across yeah and
the fact that you keep referring to it
is another form called yeah this
suggests that that actually was was part
of the genius of Einstein yeah he could
think metaphorically about something as
complex as this if that was fabulous
he had that fair to say yeah they're
really really as he hews geometrical
images a lot math unfortunately little
children love patterns and then when you
do math in school and he starts getting
messy the formulas and the yelling yeah
they nobody needs a it turns out about
two years after first year undergraduate
say two years after freshman it starts
getting beautiful and simple it gets
simples you get these these lovely
patterns if anybody saw that out that
that brakes were filmed with the Matt
Damon when he doesn't means that math
prodigy at Harford the symbols that he's
using those are actually real math
things and they're beautiful picture so
like bridges and pictures of lines and
stuff like that you get a little hint of
that with the beautiful pictures that
come out recently from chaos theory you
know that you've seen those lovely it
almost pays alike computerized images
ordinary people need computers to see
that Einstein could see it in his head I
lived for years in a little village of
the foothills of the French Alps the
footnote that is relevant and Max Ernst
had retired to that village a few years
before I was there and he'd spent many
years there the great painter and one
time I asked the woman who worked in the
bakery store I'm not especially educated
just rural French woman
what was max Aaron's like and she
pointed to a beautiful fountain outside
which a lot of art students would
sometimes come in and draw it was a
really pretty fountain and she said the
art students you know they come all the
time from grass to dragon young and
they're good but they try to sketch the
fountain max urged we try to sketch what
he thought about the fountain which I
thought was not bad coming from a a
bakery attendant in that in rural France
so Einstein saw that little bit more a
final final analogue about it George
Bernard Shaw it was once asked to
explain what was so attractive about the
music of Bach and he said roughly that
if you couldn't hear it it just sounded
like a click click click click click the
click of a mechanical sewing machine
needle click look looking but if you
could hear it you see the beautiful
multicolored woven tapestry that the
sewing machine is producing and Einstein
could see that just fabulous
he saw it very very quickly students
spend years learning to get that vision
to a mild extent what I really love and
the way that to seeing a great work of
art or a poem can open up your vision
you're experiencing those the really
touching insight that that person had to
a minor extent reading this book I hope
I tried can allow us to actually for a
moment feel what I said was feeling you
see that vision what was symbolic
becomes true I was the dream should we
on there how are we doing that time ok